guess what the minimalists are going on
tour with a live
version of the minimalists podcast and i
want to invite you to join us for a
night
of less find your nearest city at
theminimalists.com
tour we'll see you there speaking of
timeless styles what are some timeless
styles
and elements we can incorporate into our
spaces
so we aren't just chasing trends this is
a great question because the black
t-shirt i feel like is a
timeless uh style as far as what we wear
but this is a great question for
furniture
in our living spaces what what would you
consider yeah especially with your
furniture you know your furniture is you
know your sofa
things like that it's you're spending
the most money on that so do neutral
you know don't do even though i do have
a colored sofa in my collection but it's
it's green so it's more nature
green um but buy things that
large pieces that are neutral so they
will stand the test of time so later on
if you are into trends and colors you
can just change the throw pillow you can
change a rug and
your furniture is stands a test of time
so uh
shag carpet wallpaper probably
what stanley it was
oh my god yeah i remember when we were
little we were looking for a new house
and we went to see one
and they had carpet on the wall that
that like short
brown shack from the 80s i think we all
had it in our home
yeah um not on the wall but it was on
the walls and they were smokers too oh
sorry i mean i had maybe it was five and
i
vividly remember this and we walked in
and my mom walked in and walked with
goes
nope and walked right back out nope
yeah like it was up the same carpet up
the stairs up the wall in the entryway
oh you ever been to uh you ever been to
davey wayne's over
it's just like it it what you just
described is how that place feels
and except what you know sans are
smoking because you can't smoke indoors
but it's actually kind of like it's only
been there a couple times because i live
right next to it
and like it's it's interesting like
going in there and having that nostalgic
feeling um but yeah i certainly would
never want to like live
in that yeah yeah anyway
yeah it's a nice place to visit but
wouldn't want to live there exactly i
can appreciate it for what it is but man
that would not be my aesthetic let me
let me ask you about
so whether it's someone like rachel
who's trying to incorporate these sort
of timeless styles versus trends
does it differ when you talk to someone
about maybe they're moving they live in
an apartment they don't own versus
living in a home that they own
how does that change the dynamic of
interior design
i mean wouldn't that change the dynamic
just because things can't be really
permanent
um you know when it's a rental it's not
yours
um so like remove if you're really
wanting wallpaper if you're wanting to
wanted to inject your own personality
into it use removable wallpaper
um you can find great removable
wallpaper at bobbyperk.com
i really like wallpaper man my dad has a
painting and wallpaper business and so
i can't paint with crap but i could hang
like anything man like kitchen with the
soffits and the wrapping and yeah man
it's uh
i really enjoyed it's like therapeutic
hanging wallpaper the great thing about
self-adhesive removable wallpaper is you
can actually do it yourself
so if if you get regular old-school
wallpaper you
usually would need to hire somebody
because it's it's a pain in the butt
yeah
um and you need the glue and this and
that but with the removable literally
just peels off and
if you do a crooked you peel it back off
and you straighten it and
it's yeah it's something that you can do
yourself yeah i'm totally used to like
the
yeah pasting or sometimes it's
pre-pasted and you put water on there
but i didn't i didn't know that
it's like man we're living in the future
yeah this is awesome you move you just
peel it off yeah that's cool